З понеділка до п'ятниці між 7-ою та 15-ою
у цих стінах кипить робота.
Але ті, хто тут працюють, цю роботу собі не вибирали.
Це ув'язнені. У Німеччині їм платять
від одного до трьох євро на годину.
Це в рази менше від офіційної мінімальної зарплати.
У цій в'язниці в Бремерфьорде покарання відбувають
270 засуджених. Усі вони мають
трудову повинність.Зокрема, Мануель.
Моя тарифна група - четверта. Це найвища група.
Це 13-15 євро.
- На день?
Так. Це не бозна що, але трохи більше, ніж отримують інші хлопці тут.
- Ви вважаєте, цього достатньо?
Ні. Не достатньо.
Могло би бути трохи більше, бо цього не вистачає.
35 з половиною годин на тиждень.
Місячна зарплатня - 300 євро.
Це трохи більше, ніж два євро на годину.
Для порівняння: на звичайному ринку праці у ФРН
мінімальна ставка - 8 євро 84 центи на годину.
Офіційна мінімальна зарплатня - 1200 євро на місяць.
З неї зазвичай ще вираховують у пенсійний фонд.
Але в'язні, по суті, виключені з пенсійної системи.
Ув'язнені не підпадають під дію мінімальної зарплатні.
Це політичне рішення, яке я не мушу коментувати.
Але як керівник в'язниці можу сказати, що якби ми
тут мусили платити мінімалку,
то ми би не отримували взагалі ніякої роботи від підприємств.
Для нас надзвичайно важливо працевлаштовувати ув'язнених.
Уявіть собі, в'язні сім днів на тиждень сиділи б у своїй камері,
мали би кілька годин на день, щоб вийти на подвір'я і все.
Ми мали б тут значно більше заворушень та насилля,
якби ув'язнені не мали би роботи.
Утім, найбільший зиск від цього мають підприємства,
які задешево отримують свої замовлення.
Які це фірми - таємниця.
Але відомо, що в Німеччині у тюрмах виготовляють продукцію для BMW,
Daimler, Miele, Aldi, Gardena тощо.
а підрахунками DW, підприємства заплатили минулого року
понад 160 мільйонів євро
за виготовлення продукції в німецьких в'язницях.
Раік Вайґельт вважає, що виробництво у в'язницях
вбиває його бізнес.
Адже створює несправедливу конкуренцію його фірмі.
Нині із 60 працівників залишилися лише він та його дружина.
Є фірми, яким я телефонував, і вони дуже прямо в обличчя
заявляли, що так дешево, як у в'язницях,
моя фірма не може для них працювати.
У моїй галузі ця пропорція один до трьох…
- Тобто ви втричі дорожчі, ніж в'язні?
Правильно, таким чином я більше не в перегонах.
Якщо сформулювати це відверто прямим текстом,
то вони беруть злочинців, щоб ті виконували злочинну роботу.
Бо будь-який підприємець, який працює в умовах ринкової економіки
і не платить мінімальної зарплатні, соціальних відрахувань, ПДВ,
має рахуватися з тим, що його притягнуть до відповідальності.
І я запитую себе, як можна когось ресоціалізувати,
якщо ним самим - в лапках - "зловживають".
А як до такої трудової повинності ставляться саму в'язні?
І що для них при цьому важливіше - відволіктися від перебування в камері
чи та зарплатня, яку вони тут отримують.
Для мене особисто важливіше, щоб час спливав швидше.
Це важливіше, ніж зарплатня.
Хоча, з іншого боку, важко сказати, ці дві речі важко порівняти,
адже хочеться, звісно, і щось заробити.
Тож, мабуть, гроші так само важливі. Але наразі я почуваюся краще,
коли я працюю, бо так час спливає швидше.
Після роботи ув'язненні потрапляють назад до своїх камер.
Загалом таких підневільних працівників -
понад 60 тисяч по всій Німеччині.